then tony's out maury looks like he's
staying
tillman for teeth are looking at
recording reports ty lue jeff van gundy
like them both but that feels like
yo we're just gonna get we just gotta
run this back there's not a whole lot we
can do to retool this team other than
trading james harden we got no assets we
got no picks we're just gonna run this
back and let's change for changes sake
but does van gundy are lou in your mind
do they
get this team where d'antoni couldn't
get him
i'm trying to figure out why we keep
putting tyler in these situations where
this team needs a psychiatrist more than
they need to cover we're trying to push
ty lee tyler to philadelphia we're
trying to push tyler to houston neither
one of those options are really like you
know
appealing for me if i'm ty lu but to me
houston needs so much more than the head
coaching change because i don't think
mike d'antoni did anything less than
what daryl moy wanted him to do when you
present that roster with no bigs and you
tell you want james harden to control
all the possessions and then you throw
russell westbrook who can't shoot won't
defend and will not like sort of uh join
himself into what a team atmosphere sort
of with his style of play like russell's
going to be russ so tell me how a coach
is going to change that james harden is
31. his style of play is his style of
play i don't think you can win a
championship with an offensive player
like that who controls so many
possessions from one part of the floor
he's only going to control possessions
from the three-point line and out
defenses are staring at him he doesn't
go to the post he doesn't move around
without the ball you can't win like that
so i don't know what they're trying to
do other than maybe remain a different
type of second round team because unless
you change the roster
seriously they're a second round and
they might not even be
like that description
it's just a different type of second
round wow that's it
you you just don't look different and
they they
went all in on the roster right i mean
that whole thing that whole small ball
thing so it's funny you don't have
d'antoni but you still have the remnants
you got his fingerprints on the roster
whether he's there or not right no you
got daryl mori's fingerprints on the
roster the numbers man the guy who says
we're not playing basketball we're
playing numbers and what the problem is
when you play numbers and then it turns
into a playoff series invariably numbers
don't always turn out mike i won't say
numbers lie but i will say that numbers
don't always play the way that they need
to play and you saw they didn't have
enough size they could not control the
boards and those are things that cannot
bear itself out in one game exhibition
seasons which is basically what 82 games
are they are one game sample sizes and
you try to add those things up when the
playoff series you got tendencies you
got familiarity and sometimes you can't
put pj tucker on anthony davis and tell
him you know just try to bully him for
for five or six games because no matter
how hard i try
i'm five inches shorter than anthony
davis so for me unless they turn over
the roster and i think they should be
open to trading james harden to be
perfectly honest like i don't think this
roster is going anywhere else it's
expensive it's old it's unlimited it's
limit limited so i don't think any coach
jeff van gundy tyler knew rocky chuck
daley rudy tom jonovich i don't care who
you bring in you can bring in you know
teddy ruxpin you know it doesn't matter
who you bring in
this this roster is a first round team
next yeah and houston hates me but it's
okay houston
you went from the second round to the
first round